once the it is discovered that this
person is for example received the
clinical diagnosis of Parkinson and that
the actual procedure is appropriate for
them meaning that they're good you know
the pair of good health otherwise that
can handle a surgery like an autonomy or
kind of facial where is the QE
technology you're able to intervene at
craniofacial intervention or surgical
technique the surgical thing that you
can use because it's a smaller size and
you essentially use this passageway to
insert a device about 1.9 by two point
two millimeter in size which is roughly
about the grain of rice into the zone
that has been implicated in the case of
Parkinson that would be the supplement
nucleus or SCN
in the basal ganglia and you drive the
Kiwi device chip into that area it is
then made of material called carbon
nanotubes that a neurons start basically
gathering around their area and growing
a would then sense this growth of
neurons or the presence of these new
rounds start modulating
electrophysiological a modulation
pattern that is fit to stop the tremor
which is the most immediate thing that
we want to stop
so this neuromodulation happens by post
generation essentially at a very very
low power there are two other
therapeutic effects or engagement that
takes place one we refer to as a
scaffolding effect and the second is or
the third would be the optogenetics in
event that that's what we want to do is
choose regrowing cells or reprogramming
the functional area in this projection
zone the system has the capability of
communicating this data outside of the
brain to a nearby device we refer to as
the propagator and then the propagator
is able to convey or connect this
information to a system on a cloud that
is essentially a full scale referred to
as a brain operating system that is
capable of processing this data
generating additional inferences or
Corrections or modification to the
firmware or to the software and then
following the same path for a backward
again to back into the chip that process
continues on for the life of the therapy
we do inductively charging so that it's
a Quranic device we do not have to go
back and take out unless there's some
serious clinical malfunction or
malfunction or chronic malfunction of
the device which is all to be determined
and worked out in the Futurecast before
we actually go into the first patient
with this full encapsulation